[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى نبدا من رام الله في الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيليين شرقيه القدس المحتله بعد يومين
من مقتل سبعه شماليه القدس
مجلس الوزراء الامريكي
الاوضاع بعد عمليه اطلاق نار على مستوطنين
في شمال القدس المحتله امس الجمعه
والشرقيه اليوم السبت ومن واشنطن تاتين
هذه الصور قبل ساعات من بدء وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
يزور خلالها مصر واسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
نتنياهو يستبق قرارات مجلس الوزراء الامني
المصغر بالتهديد برد قوي وسريع على عمليتي
القدس ويتمسك بخطه لهدم منازل عائلات منفذ
الهجمات ودعوات في حكومته لتجميد اموال
السلطه الفلسطينيه
شرطه احتلال تسمح لاصحاب التراخيص من
المستوطنين بحمل السلاح الفصائل
الفلسطينيه تحمل الاحتلال مسؤوليه المالات
واسماعيل هنيه يحذر من ان المنطقه تتجه
نحو صعيدا غير مسبوقه
وغداه مقتل سبعه اسرائيليين في عمليه في
ضواحي القدس اصابه مستوطنين في اطلاق نار
ببلده سلوان في القدس نفذه فتى فلسطيني
اشتباكات في مخيم شعفاط ومحاوله دهس جنوب
نابلس والاحتلال يدفع بمزيد من القوه
في ردود الفعل الدوليه ومع ترقب الوصول
الى المنطقه مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه
يواصل محادثاته واشنطن تقول انه يبحث مع
الجانبين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني تصاعد
العنف والاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو الى التهدئه
والى اعاده التنسيق الامني لمنع العنف
ويعبر عن خشيته من مزيد من التوكل
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اصابه مستوطنين في ضاحيه
سلوان الشرقيه القدس غازات مقتل سبعه
اخرين في اطلاق نار شماليه المدينه وقرر
القائد العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه نشر وحده
قوات خاصه بشكل دائم في القدس الاستجابه
للتطورات العاجله وتعليقا على توجيهات
اسرائيليه بشان الاسرى الفلسطينيين قال
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحماس اسماعيل هنيه
ان المنطقه متجهه الى تصعيد الغير مسبوق
وان المواجهه لن تبقى داخل السجون
باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثاني في رايكم ما هي
المسارات المحتمله في ظل التوتر الراهن في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله 28% توقعوا ان
يساعد الاحتلال ممارساته ضد الفلسطينيين
بينما توقع اربعه 54% اتساعها عن طاقه
عمليات المقاومه ضد الاحتلال ورجح 18%
تدخل خارجيا لخفض التوتر وت التصعيد هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كي
ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد التوافق الغربي على امداد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات كيف تكشف عن مفاوضات جديده
للحصول على طائرات وصواريخ بعيده الماده
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان الرد على العمليات الاخيره في
القدس
عمليات اصدار تراخيص السلاح المدنيين كما
سيتم تسريعه وتكثيفه وعمليات هدم منازل
قواتها منتشره ومعززه وجاهزه للتعامل مع
كل احتمال واي فاي
ردوا ناس يكون قويا وسريعا ودقيقه من
يحاول المسافه بنا سنضربه ونضرب من يساعده
لقد نفذنا عمليه اعتقال واسعه للضم ايدي
الارهاب ومساعدهم والمحرضين لقد نشرنا
القوات وعززنا القوات وذلك على جبهات
مختلفه سنهادم منازل المخربين باجراء سريع
وذلك لجبايه ثمن اضافي من اولئك الذين
يؤيدون الارهاب وهذه العمليه بدات امس وهي
في ذروتها الان من جهه التامه وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي ثمار بن جرير المستشاره
القضائيه للحكومه بعرق التي طلبته اغلاق
منزلي
عائلتين منفذي الهجومين في حي يعقوب
الاستطلاني سلوان في القدس وقال من كبير
خلال زيارته جرح الهجوم المسلح في سلوان
انه يريد تنفيذ سلسله من الاجراءات ضد
فلسطينيين بعمليات بعمليات قتل فيها
اسرائيليون منها هدم منازل وسن قانون
اعدام الاسره
لانه استاذه شريط وما بعد ساعتين بالاضافه
الى قضيه غلق المنزل الذي عرقلته
المستشاره القضائيه هناك سلسله من
الاجراءات التي طلبت تنفيذها فورا واتمنى
ان لا تتم عرقلتها واولها هدم المنازل غير
القانونيه لدهشه هناك عشرات المنازل في
القدس التي لم يتم هدمها بعد وقد وجهت
الشرطه للاستعداد لهدمها كما كان هناك
قضيه السلاح اريد من مواطن اسرائيل ان
يحمل سلاحا ليدافع عن انفسهم كما نريد
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلى قرارا باغلاق
المستوطنات المحيطه بالقدس امام العماله
الفلسطينيه وجاء القرار بعد مشاورات امنيه
اجرها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع رئيس
جهاز الشباب ورئيس هيئه اركان الجيش هذا
وكان وزير الماليه الاسرائيليه المتطرف
بتسلئيل سيموتريتش قد طالب في المجلس
الوزاري الامني المصغر بمحافظه الاحياء
التي تعيش فيها عائلات منفذ الهجمات
وتزميد اموال السلطه الفلسطينيه
وكان مستوطنان اسرائيليان قد اصيب بجراح
بعد اطلاق نار عليهما بضاحيه سلوان شرقيه
القدس المحتله وقد يعتقل محمد عليوه الفتى
البالغ من العمر 13 عاما بعد اصابته ونقله
للمستشفى وتتهم الشرطه الفلسطينيه الطفل
عليه روايه بتنفيذ العمليه السلطه
الاسرائيليه تتهممه بتنفيذ العمليه بينما
ينفي اهله ذلك وتاتي عمليه سلوان بعد
ساعات من مقتل سبعه مستوطنين في هجوم نفذه
شاب فلسطيني في قلب حين بيعقوب السطاني
الشماليه القدس المحتله ووصفته الشرطه
بالاعنه في ذلك الوقت
عمليه اطلاق نار اخرى في القدس المحتله
والمتهم بتنفيذها فتى يبلغ من العمر 13
عاما عمليه اسفرت عن اصابه مستوطنين
احدهما ضابط في الجيش بينما اصيب الفتى
بنيران مستوطن فنقل الى المستشفى تحت
حراسه مشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وفي ثلاثه ايام الماضيه وحدها في مدينه
القدس اربع شهداء وما زال الاحتلال يحرك
بخصوص بن كبير حينما يقوم بتكريم القتله
قطره الفتره محمد علي في مخيم شعفاط
والسياسات التنكريه الاحتلاليه في مدينه
القدس
بعد العمليه اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال منزل
العائله في بلده سلوان واعتقلت والديه
وشقيقه كما عززت قواتها واستدعت مزيدا من
الوحدات الخاصه الى البلدات والاحياء
الفلسطينيه في القدس المحتله وذلك بعد ان
اعلنت عن رفع حاله التاهب الى الدرجه
القصوى
اجراءات قد تكون مقدمه لتصعيد محتمل يحمل
الجانب الفلسطيني مسؤوليه حدوثه وتداعياته
للجانب الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني
الحوار الوطني الشامل من اجل مواجهه مرحله
غايه في الدقه والتحديات بالاضافه الى
دعوه العالم والاداره الامريكيه لاتخاذ
موقف سيامو انه انعدام العدل يعني استمرار
عدم الاستقرار وعدم تحقيق مطالب الشعب
الفلسطيني سيعني استمرار المواجهه وقعت
هذه العمليه وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده وبعد
ساعات على عمليه اطلاق نار في حي نفي
يعقوب الاستيطامي اسفلت عن مقتل سبعه
اسرائيليين عمليه عبرت الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه عن مخاوفها من ان تشكل حافزا
لشبان اخرين لا ينتمون الى تنظيمات بعينها
فيقدم على تنفيذ عمليات مماثله ويصعب
احباطها ولعل ابرز المخاوف الاسرائيليه ان
تنتقل المواجهه الى مدينه القدس في ظل
حكومه اقصى اليمين المتطرف تلجا سلطاته
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى تصعيد العمليات
والاجراءات ضد الفلسطينيين وهو ما قد
يقودوا الى تفجر الاوضاع لا سيما وان كل
تصعيد اسرائيلي يقابله تصعيد فلسطيني بل
ومزيد
من الاصرار على المواجهه
نجوى سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله
من رام الله وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره اهلا بكما واذا ما بدانا من
الاجتماع
الياس اعتقد هذا الاجتماع ما زال مستمرا
ما الذي يتوقع منه
بفعل عثمان والتوقعات تسير بمسيرين المسار
الاول هو انتقامي والمسار الثاني هو
عمليات امنيه في الميدان
المسار الاول وهو الانتقام من الفلسطينيين
جاء كان واضحا على لسان بعض الوزراء
المتطرفين في هذه الحكومه اليمنيه الذين
دعوا الى العديد من الاجراءات من
الانتقاميه من الفلسطينيين سواء الجماعيه
او تلك المتعلقه بعائلات منافذيه العمليات
المسلحه من قبل اغلاق منازلهم وهدمها وطرد
عائلاتهم من القدس الى الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ومحاصره الاحياء العربيه في القدس
المحتله بحواجزه وباجراءات النيه لكن من
الواضح بان هذه الاجراءات الانتقاميه التي
تشمل ايضا بحسب ما طلبه وزير الامن القومي
ايضا المنازل غير المرخصه في القدس
المحتله هذه الاجراءات كلها تصطدم
بمعيقات قضائيه وبمظه من المستشاره
القضائيه للحكومه التي قد تعيق او تاخر
هذه الاجراءات وتنفيذها على ارض الواقع من
ناحيه اخرى هنالك مطالب لبعض الوزراء في
تعزيزي السلاح بيد الاسرائيليين وتمكينهم
من حيازه السلاح وتعجيل منحهم التراخيص
اللازمه من اجل ذلك على الاقل له وزير
الامن القومي لتماربه لكن الاهم عثمان كما
يبدو هو ما سيتمثل من اجراءات في الميدان
وكان لافتا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن
عن دفعي تعزيزات الى الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ثلاث كتائب اضافيه تضاف منها
وحدات قتاليه تضاف الى الكتيبه التي كان
دفع بها الجيش الاسرائيلي من لواء
المظليين يوم الجمعه الماضي وهذه كلها
تضاف الى اربعه 10 كتيبه همم في داخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي من ال- وحدات النظاميه
التي يفطر انها تدرب من اجل القتال على
جبهات اخرى لكن يدفع بها لتعزيز الوجود
العسكري في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وهنالك
كما يبدو مخططات ربما لم يعلن عنها المجلس
الوزار المصغر بعد انتهاء اجتماعه
المتواصل لحتى هذه الساعه اجراءات عملاتيه
عسكريه امنيه في محاصره المقاتلين
والمسلحين تحديدا في منطقتي جنين ونابلس
وربما فرض اجراءات امنيه صارمه وعزل مناطق
بعينها تحديدا تلك المناطق القريبه من
نابلس وجنين وايضا فرض تعزيزات امنيه
واسعه على محاور الطرق التي يسلكها
المستوطنون في الضفه الغربيه المحتله من
غير المستبعد ان تكون هنالك ايضا اجراءات
تتعلق في دخول العمال الفلسطينيين الى
المناطق الصناعيه الموجوده في
المستوطنات او في الكتل الاستيطانيه
الكبرى لكن حتى هذه الساعه لا يوجد ما
يؤكد همم بان قرارات اتخذت في هذا الصيام
ايضا يا طال هذا الاجراء ايضا عشرات الاف
العمال الفلسطينيين الذين يدخلون الى
اسرائيل من داخل قطاع غزه رغم ان اسرائيل
تحاول الفصل في قراراتها بين الضفه وبين
قطاع غزه لكن بالمجمل العام عثمان التركيز
سيكون الان على مدينه القدس وهي ربما نقطت
الضعف او عقب اخيل كما تسميها اسرائيل ذلك
ان الفلسطينيين الذين يعيشون في مدينه
القدس يحملون ال- همم
البطاقه بطاقه الهويه الاسرائيليه ويمكنهم
ان ينتقلوا بحريه وبسهوله بين الضفه
الغربيه المحتله والقدس هنالك خشيه بان
تستمر على العمليات المسلحه من خلال تهريب
السلاحا من داخل الضفه الغربيه الى القدس
وتنفيذي مزيدا من العمليات لذلك
استمعناش وزير الماليه الذي يدعو الى فرض
حصار على هذه الاحياء وهذا من غير
المستبعد لان اسرائيل لجات الى هذا
الاسلوب في عام 2015 و2016
مشاهدت القدس عمليات الدهس والطعم الكبرى
وبالتالي من غير المستبعد ان تشدد قوات
الشرطه الاسرائيليه شرطه الاحتلال من
وجودها على الحواجز العسكريه المؤديه بين
الضفه الغربيه والقدس وكذلك على الاحياء
العربيه بين الاحياء العربيه طبعا
والشطر الغربي للقدس واجراء تفتيشات واسعه
هناك المفوض العام للشرطه بقي ان نقول
عثمان اعلن عن تعزيز واسع ونشر واسع لشرطه
الاحتلال في القدس وزير الدفاع يقول بانه
سيعزز همم قوه الشرطه الاسرائيليه بوحدات
قتاليه من الجيش والمفوض العام للشرطه
اعلنا بانه دفع ونشر وحدات اليمام وهي
الوحدات الخاصه في مكافحه الارهاب في
القدس من اجل منعه مزيد من العمليات
المسلحه التي قد تشهدها المدينه
شكرا لك قبل ان نذهب الى وليد عمرو يشير
الى المواجهات التي اندلعت بين شبان
فلسطينيين وافراد من شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مخيم شعفاط شرقيه مدينه
القدس المحتله وقد استخدم المحتجون
الفلسطينيون الالعاب الناريه والحجاره ضد
الجنود الاحتلال الذين ردوا باطلاق قنابل
الغاز المسيله للدموع لقمع الشبان
الفلسطينيين في المخيم كمن دلعت مواجهات
في مناطق اخرى من ضواحي مدينه القدس
وبلداتها فاقتحمت شرطه الاحتلال مناطق
الطور وجبل المكبر
وصور باهر العيساويه في المدينه
الله
ولعت ولعت ولع
يا اولاد
عاجل الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطينيين في مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في
بيتا وذلك الجنوبيه نابلس
ااه الجيش الاسرائيلي جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قال ان مسلح عن كذلك اطلق
الرصاص تجاه مطعم في منطقه الاغوار على
طريق اريحا القدس واكد جيش الاحتلال عدم
وقوع اي اصابات في الهجوم مشيرا الى ان
قوته كما قال تمشط المنطقه بحثا عن
المهاجم ورجح جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تعطر سلاح المهاجم فتره لان اا يلوث
بالفرار نعود الى مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري همم يعني اسماعيل هنيه يقول تصعيد
نحن نتجه نحو الصعيد غير مسبوق كثيرون
ربما يتفقون معه كيف تصف لنا همم الوضع
على الارض الان والابداع
الموقف متصاعد من ساعه الى اخرى ومن يوم
الى اخر واليومين الاخرين شاهداني على ذلك
سواء منذ الاجتياح الاسرائيلي او العمليه
العسكريه في مخيم جنين التي خلفت تسعه
شهداء فلسطينيين ومن ثم الرد الفلسطيني
عليها في الحي الاستيطاني يعقوب حيث قتل
سبعه من الاسرائيليين واليوم الهجوم ايضا
الذين نفذوه في الثالث عشر من عمره واطلق
النار على مستوطنين في ضاحيه سلوان الوضع
يسير نحو الانفجار السؤال المطروح الان ان
هذه التوليفه اليمنيه الحاكمه وهي من اقصى
اليمين المتطرف هي جريحه جريحه بمعنى ان
لم تتوقع ان يكون هناك رد بهذه القوه وفي
هذا الموقع وهو القدس وفي هذه السرعه من
جانب الفلسطينيين وبهذه الحصيله ايضا من
القتلى الاسرائيليين لذلك هي تعتبر جريحه
ايضا لان
جمهورها بدا يلومها بانها حاول نتنياهو
ومن معه سموثج ومن كبير وغيرهم ان يسوقوا
له بانهم هم الاقدر على تحقيق الامن
المطلق له وهذا ما يشير الى انها في
اسابيعها الاولى قد ادت الى هذا الوضع همم
المهزوز امنيا لدرجه ان هناك من يتحدث عن
حاله من الذعر في اوساط المستوطنين والامر
والاهم من هذا كله انا مركز الثقه اللي
انتقل الى القدس وهذا ما يثير قلقا كبيرا
لدى الاسرائيليا اي انه كان في فتره في
جنين انتقل الى نابلس لكن الان المركز
الثقل هو في القدس المحتله واحياها تعتبر
ان القدسها الموحده والابديه كما يردد
قادتها وقامت بضمك كافه الاحياء حولها
وايضا كان قامت بعمليه تسمين الاستيطانيه
لها لذلك هم بيكون وقد تكون اجراءاتهم مثل
ما وصفها الياس قد تكون اجراءاتهم فعلا
اجراءات همم
وان جربوا على الفلسطينيين كل الاجراءات
القمعيه والانتقاميه لكن هذه المره قد
يحاولون ولو من باب التظاهر ان يقوم
باجراءات على نطاق اوسع
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الضفه الغربيه شهدت
صحيح بعض المناوشات في شعفاطات وفي جبل
المكبر والطور وكان هناك اعتداءات
للمستوطنين ايضا في منطقه نابلس وكان هناك
عمليه اطلاق نار ثالث وان قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها لم تنجح بسبب تعطل سلاح
المهاجم الا ان واضح ان الوضع متوتر وسط
اجراءات امن هائله واستثنائيه تقوم فيها
قوات الاحتلال واجهزتها الامنيه في كافه
اجزاء الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في منطقه
القدس الاصوات التي تخرج عن الطاقه من
وزاره التشير الى ان هناك منافسه منهم
ياتي بالحل السحري او القمع الا شده
والامل للفلسطينيين شكرا جزيلا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره متحدثا الينا من
رام الله وفي خلفيه التطورات الميدانيه
التي تسارعت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه تبدو في
الواجهه ملامح واستراتيجيه حكومه بنيامنه
الياهو نحو مواجهه الاوضاع في الضفه ورفع
منسوب الاشتباكات والاقتحامات لكن ذلك
يطرحوا اسئلته بشان لماذا قدرت خطط
اسرائيليه السابقه على تحقيق نتائج فعله
رئاسه الحكومه استمرار الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه وعمليات المقاومه
ابرزها اقتحام جنين المدينه والبخيم قبل
ايام دخلته قوات الاحتلال بغطاء مدني في
شاحنه مواد غذائيه الا ان فصائل المخيم
رصدت التوغل واشتبكت مع القوه المهاجمه
قبل توليه المنصب اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
مخيم جنين وشنه عمليات دهن وتفتيش وبعد
توليه المنصب ساعات اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
البلده القديمه في نابلس ايام قليله
وتقتحم قوه الاحتلال منطقه المخفيه والجبل
الشمالي في نابلس فجرا وتشتبك مع مقاومين
لتنفذ في الثالث من كانون الثاني يناير
اقتحاما لمخيم بلاطه وتشتبك مع مجموعات
مقاومه وبعد اقل من اسبوعين على تولي
نتنياهو منصبه اقتحمت قوته الاحتلال مخيم
بلاطه في نابلس للمره الثانيه كذلك محاوله
مجموعه خاصه من قوات الاحتلال التسلل الى
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه نابلس الا ان
فصائل المقاومه رصدت وجودها واشتبكت معها
وتكررت العمليه في المنطقه الشرقيه من
المدينه بعد ايام
كم استهدفت قوات الاحتلال قطاع غزه مع
تولي نتنياهو الحكم في المقابل هجمات عند
نفذها مقاومون فلسطينيون في الضفه الغربيه
على مواقع عسكريه ومستوطنات من بينها حاجز
حواره
ومستوطنتين وكادومي الا ان العمليه
الابرزه منذ وصول نتنياهو كانت فين في
يعقوب الذات الى مقتل وجرح اسرائيليين
نفذها بشكل منفرد شاب لم ينتمي لاين من
الفصائلتها عمليه اطلاق نار اخرى قرب
السلوان
اهديولوجيا نتنياهو ووزراءه في بيان الثقه
امام الكنيست حيث تعهد بالعمل على تطوير
الاستيطان والحفاظ على الطابع اليهودي
للدوله وتعزيز مكانه القدس عاصمه لاسرائيل
وزياده الهجره اليها فوضع بذلك خارطه طريق
لعمل طريقه لكنيست لم يكن بعيدا فاقر بشكل
تمهيدي مشروعا نزع الجنسيه عن اسرى القدس
مع تنام خطاب الكراهيه والتحريض ضد
الفلسطينيين
وزير الامن القومي تماربين كثير دعا الى
تهجير الفلسطينيين وتوعد بتمرير قوانين
لفرض حكم الاعدام على مقاومين ومنحي حصانه
لجنود الجيش
وخطب وزير الماليه
الفلسطينيين بالقول اسرائيل ليست دولتكم
القوميه يمكنكم العيش هنا اذا قبلتم
باسرائيل دوله يهوديه
الاسرائيلي ومن حيث جاك خوري الكاتب
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه السيد ماهر
هل يمكن عزل كل ما يحدث الان عن التصعيد
الكبير الذي كان من جانب الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو عندما قتل تسعه فلسطينيين في جنين
وكان ذلك شراره همم لكل ما تشهده الاراضي
الفلسطينيه الان
نعم
بين الفلسطينيين التسعه الذين قتلوا في
جنين سته او سبعه كانوا من المسلحين
الناشطين وهذا امر يجري دائما طبعا انا لا
احبذ السياسات نتنياهو لكن هذا الامر لم
يبدا في ظل حكوماته هذه الهجمات كان
مصدرها ضفه الغربيه في السابق وهذه
الاجراءات هي من بين التدابير التي يتخذها
الجيش الاسرائيلي من خلال ضرب الذين
يحاولون ان يضربوا اسرائيل اولا هذا هو
جزء من الاستراتيجيه حتى اي وقت سوف تعمل
هذه الاستراتيجيه بالطريقه المهجوره لا
اعرف ولكن نحن نتحدث عن نزاعا بيننا وبين
الفلسطينيين ولسوء الحظ لا ارى المخرج
سيد جاكي خوري
كثيرون في الجانب الفلسطيني تحديدا يرون
ان ما حدث في جنين هو الذي اطلق كل ما
يحدث الان وسيد ماريا يقول لا هذا لله
علاقه له بحكومه نتنياهو ولكن يحدث دائما
وهذه اجراءات السباقيه وان اكثر من قتل
كان من المسلح
مساء الخير يعني واضح انه كل ما يحدث الان
هو نتيجه تراكميه لسلسله اهداف يعني انا
اتفق مع ضيفك بجزئيه واحده لان الاحداث لم
تبدا فقط في الاسبوع الاخير وفي الايام
الاخيره وتحديدا ما كان في جنين من يتابع
الاحداث على مدار السنه الاخيره ولا
اسابيع الاخيره وهو ما كان بانتقال سلسال
يقول من حكومته همم يعني بنت ولا بيدي لا
حكومه نتانيا اهو هي المزيد من الاقتحامات
لمدن الضفه الغربيه وللمخيمات الفلسطينيه
بمفهوم السياسه هي نفس السياسه بالبعد
الامني والعسكري الاستخباراتى ولكن
المختلف طبعا هذه المره بالنسبه لعدد يعني
الضحايا والشهداء الذين سقطوا في جنين في
نهايه الاسبوع وهي بامر كما ذكرت تراكميه
وبالتالي عندما نصل الان نتخطى حاجز
الشهيد او اثنين او ثلاثه كما كان خلال
العام الماضي والاسابيع الاخيره في ج في
نابلس وفي مناطق مختلفه عندما تصل الامور
الى حد تسعه قتلى في خلال ساعتين في مخيم
جنين واقتحام قوات كبيره جدا بعشرات
الجنود المتجدده باسلحتهم وتناقل هذه
الصور عبر شبكات التواصل بشكل سريع واضح
انه لهذا الامر واقع كبير على الساحه
الفلسطينيه اذا كان في الضفه الغربيه واذا
كان في قطاع غزه وبالتالي جاء رد الفعل
بشكل مباشر في قناه سياسيه في التبرير همم
بالقول انه يعني سته من التسعه كانوا
مسلحين كما يقول اسرائيل
ملائم للروايه الاسرائيليه للراي العامل
الاسرائيلي ولكن لا اعتقد انه هذا يؤثر
بشيء اه في الساحه الفلسطينيه بمفهوم ان
ردود الفعل عمليا توالت على هذا الحدث
بعدد الشهداء طبعا وبقراءه الفلسطيني لما
يحدث من عمليات اقتحام المتكرره وزياده
وتيره هذه الاحداث يعني طبعا بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ولو اشير الى قضيه اخرى انه
مباشره بعد العمليه وبدون حتى ان ينتهي
التحقيق في هذا الامر بما في ذلك الدقيق
الداخلي صار او وزير الامن القومي وكذلك
قياده الاجهزه الامنيه الى منح نيشين لعدد
من عناصر القوه الاثريه التي اقتحمت عمليا
الاجواء كانت احتفاليه
يعني انقل ذلك السيد همم يعني مهما قال
الاسرائيليون فهم اذا يدركون جيدا ان هذا
سوف يؤدي الى ردود فعل وهم همم كانوا
يعلمون الفلسطينيين لن يسكت هو بداوا
بالاحتفال بالناشئين وغير ذلك ما يقول
الروايه الاسرائيليه يعني بالنسبه للجانب
الفلسطيني لا تعني الكثير والاسرائيليون
وحكومه نتنياهو كانت تعلم الى اين تتجه
بعمليه من هذا النوع
طبعا ما من فعل لا ياتي بعده رد فعل هذا
هو جزء معروف في هذا النزاع الماساوي ولكن
بكل صراحه هناك فرق بين
استهداف في هدف
عسكري ناشط سته اشخاص سبعه اشخاص قد لا
يهم للفلسطينيين او للجزيره ولكن هذا مهم
بالنسبه الينا في اسرائيل لاننا شاهدنا
عددا من عمليه اطلاق النار في شوارعنا
وبالتالي هناك فرق بين استهداف الاهداف
العسكريه او المسلحه ولسوء الحظ في نفس
الهجوم همم يؤدي الهجوم الى مقتل ابرياء
ولكن هذا لا يقارن في مجزره في
معبد اليهودي وبالتالي لا اعتقده ان همم
الناس عندما ذهبوا
سعره يعتقدون انهم سوف يتعرضون لهذه
المجزره وما تفاجات به اسرائيل هو السعاده
والفرح في اوساط الفلسطينيين بعد هذه
المجدده هذه هي المفاجاه الكبرى اااه حسنا
عموما يعني لا ادري لماذا ادخلت الجزيره
كجزء من هذا الموضوع هو مجرد سؤال المهني
طرحته عليك وطرحته وهناك جانب فلسطيني معك
في هذا الحوار سيد جاكي همم الان برايك
الى اين سوف تتجه الامور في المستقبل
الموضوع
يعني اعتقد الاحد يملك الاجابه الواضحه
على هذا السؤال
بيني مهمين يعني اولا التصاعد الاحداث
ولابد ان نقول ذلك يعني قبل يومين عندما
اعلنت القياده الفلسطينيه عن وقف التنسيق
الامني واضح ان ردود الفعل ترتبط بالاساس
بالضفه الغربيه وعندما دخل الوسطاء
بالنسبه لمنع التصعيد في قطاع غزه فلهم
تاثير ونفوذ فى قطاع غزه لربما امام
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والحسابات تكون هناك
في مسرح اخر الذي حصل هو في مدينه القدس
التي تقطع بشكل كامل لكل سيطره
الاسرائيليه امنيا
وسياسيا بحكمه طبعا يتطورات لا ندخل فيها
الان ولكن يعني حتى موضوع التنسيق الامني
لا يلعب دور لما يرتبط في القدس وكذلك اي
وساطه عربيه او اجنبيه في هذا الموضوع
وبالتالي تصاعد الاحداث القدس قد يكون
الان المفتاح بيدها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التي يتبارى الان وزراء كيف
سيعاقبون نظره الفلسطيني على ما حدث واضح
ان المزيد من التصعيد معناه ايضا المزيد
من ردود الفعل وبالتالي يبقى طرف واحد او
ثلاثه اطراف على هذا المسرح عليه اداره
الامريكيه الرئيس المصري والعهد الاردني
شكرا جزيلا لكم من حيث جاك خوري الكاتب
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن تل ابيب
مائير جردان الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
الاسرائيلي
وقد دفع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بكتيبه
ثالث سائل الضفه الغربيه واستحاله امنيه
واعلن المفتش العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه
رساله وحده العمليات الخاصه المعروفه
بوحده يمام الى القدس ويثير وهذا
الاستغفار الامريكي اسئله مش يعني حجم
القوات الاسرائيليه التي تتعامل يوميا مع
الاوضاع في الضفه وماذا قدرتها على السباق
اي عمليه فلسطين
اسرائيل واعلنت نشر وحده القوات الخاصه
يمام بشكل دائم في القدس وهي واحده من
اربع وحدات تتبع لشرطه حرس الحدود تعمل في
القدس ومناطق الدفه الغربيه واغلب عناصرها
من جنود الجيش الاحتلال السابقين الذين
خدموا في وحده القتال الخاصه تنقسم الوحده
لعده فرق ومنذ انتفاضه الثانيه تركز عملها
على الاغتيالات وتصفيه النشطاء وبشكل عام
تتشكل المنظومه الامنيه الاسرائيليه من
عدد من الاجهزه ابرزها الجيش اهم مؤسسه
واكبر من الله جهاز الشباب ويعمل تحت
اشراف رئيس الوزراء يهدف للقضاء على ما
يسميه الارهاب الداخلي وتامين المناطق
الحيويه في اسرائيل ويعمل بما تقسيمه
المناطقيه ويعتبر القطاع العربي واكبرها
شرطه اسرائيل وهي جهاز يهتم بالامن
الداخلي والحفاظ على النظام العام في
اسرائيل
اليها في البدايه
حرس الحدود وحده قتاليه تابعه مباشره
لشرطه اسرائيل لمنع تسلل اليها ويتدخل حرس
الحدود وقت الحاجه وفقا لتوجيهات وزير
الشرطه لصد مظاهرات او قمع مسكره
واعتصامات
[موسيقى]
في ردود الفعل الفلسطيني حملت حركه فتح
الحكومه الاسرائيليه النتائج المترتبه على
سياستها التي وصفتها بالفاشيه وقال
المتحدث باسم حركه فتح في بيان صحفي ان
حكومات الاحتلال المتعاقبه اغلقت كل
الابواب وتركت باب المواجهه والقتل
والاعتقالات وانتهاك المقدسات من جانبه
دعى رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس
اسماعيل هنيه قاده العالم والشعوب الحره
الى التدخل لوقف جرائم ابن جبير وما وصفها
بحكومه اليمين الفاشيه واضاف هنيه ان
المنطقه متوجهه الى تصعيد غير مسموح وان
المواجهه لن تبقى داخل السجون من جهتها
قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي في بيان ان
المقاومه حيه وباقيه وان عمليتي القدس
ضربتها المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه
كما اكدت الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين ان
الصراع مفتوح مع الاحتلال وان عمليه سلوان
تاكيد على الهويه الفلسطينيه للقدس
في اوجه التطورات الحاليه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله يلفت الانتباه ان منفذ
عمليه اليوم التي اصيب فيها مستوطنان
اسرائيليان فتى لا يتجاوز من العمر 13
عاما ما الذي يدفع صبيا في مقتل في مقتبل
العمر الى تعريض حياته للخطر واسرته
للتنكيل من قبل قوات الاحتلال وهل تترك
تصرفاته اسرائيليين من قوات ومستوطنين
ومتشددين اخرين خيارات امام الفلسطيني
قبل ان تجف دماء شهداء ما وصفت بمجزره
مخيم جنين قبل يومين طلق الاحتلال ضربه
ثانيه من المكان من جدران سلوان خرج صار
الفتى شجره نبتته اوراقت في لحظه غرسه في
ارضه وحوله اغراب اطلق الرصاص جزعوا
تراقضوا في كل صوب جرح مستوطنين احدهما
ضابط كان في عطله قبل ان يصاب بجروح خطره
برصاص الماره وفق التلفزيون الاسرائيليه
والمره هناك هم المستوطنون المدنيون
المسلحون مفارقه اخرى من سمات اسرائيل
الخاصه جنه جنون الاحتلال من يكون الفتاه
انه في الثالثه عشر الجزء الاخر من الصدمه
لكن الاسره التي نفاثه وقالت ان ابنها كان
مرا هناك بالصدفه داهمت قوات الاحتلال
منزلها واعتقلت افرادا من العائله ايا كان
اسم المنفذ هو طفل فلسطيني ممن ينبغي لهم
ان يكونوا في مدرسه او نادي رياضي او يلهو
مع اللاهين في لعب الطفوله لكنها فلسطين
حيث لا شيء عادي ولا طبيعيه وحيث الاطفال
يرون اطفالا تحمل الى المقابر اجساده تنزف
لقد شاهدهم العالم ومعه فتسلوان قبل اشهر
قليله في جبل وفي غيرها وقبلها وبعدها
وكان من المحمولين منهم في عمره واصغر
في فلسطين يقتل الاطفال ويعدمون على
الطرقات ويعتقلون وحسب الجاني من العقاب
وثائق تسلم للاسره الدوليه عن 52 طفلا
فلسطينيا قتلهم الاسرائيليون العام الماضي
فقط ومع ذلك لا محكمه جنائيه ولا لائحه
عار بل تساؤل فجر على شكل صدمه كيف لهذا
العنف ان يكبر في النفوس الصغيره هجوم
سلوان اعقب هجوما هز اركان الحكومه
الموصوفه بالاشد تطرفا في مستوطنه نيفي
يعقوب يوم الجمعه راحت اجهتها الامنيه
تتعاقب على مواقع الهجوم وظهر الوزير
لتامر بن كثير وسط الحشد لا يسعفه في وجهه
صرخاتهم سوى تمني الموت للعرب والهاتفون
الغاضبون لا يطلبون السلام بل يقرعونه
للتقصير ثم تبدا الافكار والاقتراحات من
راس الهرم بين يم ثانيه اهو بترحيل عائلات
المنفذين او اعتقالهم مما يندرج في جريمه
دوليه اخرى اسمها العقاب الجماعيه ماذا
سيفعلون اكثر براي مراقبين فان الهجمات
المنطلقه على شكل فدائيين افراد شبان صغار
من الجيل الثالث او الرابع للاحتلال تضع
اسرائيل كلها في مازقه بشقها السياسي
ممثلا بحكومه معتزه والامني بشقه
الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه في الفدائيون
الجدد يعملون وحدهم كل فرد فصيل وكل سلاح
متاح
والاجولوجيا كلمتان رفض الاحتلال اما
الجغرافيا في فلسطين كلها كل بيت وكل عقل
وكل روح حره سيكون على العالم ومن بينه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه القادم الى
المنطقه
في ما وراء الاجراءات والضغط على السلطه
الفلسطينيه
طلب ضبط النفس من الاحتلال مع صياغات
مكروره عن عمليه سلام ترقد في غيبوبه
الموت ليدرك انما يدفع شبابا لدفع الحياه
خلفهم هيا ابسط قوانين الطبيعه واشدها
تعقيده الفعل ورد الفعل الاحتلال
والمقاومه
[موسيقى]
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت الدكتور علي ما
مدى خطوره ما يحدث الى اين يمكن ان يتجه
يعني واضح انه الاوضاع كانت في تصاعد
المواجهه كانت في تصاعد منذ فتره طويله
منذر الحكومه السابقه
ووصلت الان حكومه يمنيه متطرفه تعلن يعني
جهارا بانها تريد ان تضم الضفه بانها تريد
ان تزيد الاستيطان بان لا مكان
للفلسطينيين هنا لذلك يعني التصعيد هو سيد
الموقف ما شاهدناه في خلال اليومين
الماضيين سيستمر
ويتصاعد والنقطه المهمه ان رد همم الفعل
على ما حدث في جنين جاء من القدس
وهذا يعني يثير بالنسبه للحكومه الجديده
هاي اليمني التي جاءت لتحل مشكله اسرائيل
تجاه الفلسطينيين وتقمع الفلسطينيين جاء
الرد سريعا من القدس حيث تسيطر اسرائيل
بالكامل على همم الفلسطينيين الموجودين
فيها العمليات الفرديه لا تست في اسرائيل
ان تتحكم بمعنى دكتور علي هل هل هذا يعني
همم اظهار فشل امني بهذه الحكومه التي
جاءت بوعود امنيا للاسرائيليين
واضح تماما يعني بنجفير كان في مكان همم
الحادث في القدس وكان هناك من المستوطنين
هتافات ضده بانه لم ياتي بالامن همم الذي
وعد به وهو وزير الامن في في
من اول يوم دخل فيه هذه الحكومه
وتصريحات عنصريه وتصريحات ضد الفلسطينيين
وبانه سيقوم بكل الاجراءات فهذا هو الرد
لذلك هذا ما تقلق منه هذه الحكومه المهتزه
لانها مهتسه ايضا في الداخل الليلي بالذات
كان في مظاهرات ضدها في تل ابيب على قضايا
اخرى يعني
انقلب السحر على الساحر انجاز التعبير ام
ان ااه هذا يعني فيه مبالغه القول بهذا
الامر وربما ما زال الوقت مبكرا
لا هو انقلب انقلب بمعنى ان رد الفعل يعني
هم سيفعلون ولكن جاءهم رد فعل لم يكونوا
يتوقعوه وليس بهذه الصوره وليس في هذا
المكان وليس بهذه النتيجه لذلك الان في
حسابات جديده سيحاولون ان يقمعوا
الفلسطينيين جيش اكثر في الضفه في القدس
اغلاق حواجز على الطرق كل هذا سيقومون به
ولكن هذا سياتي ايضا بردود فعل لن يتوقف
الجانب الفلسطيني لانه خصوصا بالعمليات
هذه الفرديه لن يتوقف الجانب الفلسطيني
لذلك هم دخلوا في هذه الدوامه وهذه حكومه
تواجه اشكاليات داخليه داخل اسرائيل فهي
ستحاول بشهدها ان تضبط الاوضاع ولكن لا
اظن بانها ستكون قادره وفي نهايه المطاف
مثل ما حدث في السابق في السابق نتنياهو
نشد نشد العديد من قيادات المنطقه من اجل
التهدئه سيحصل نفس الشيء النهايه شكرا
جزيلا لك من رام الله الدكتور علي
الجرباوي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرسل
هذه التطورات تعيد الى الواجهه ما شهدته
السنه الماضيه من احداث دانيه على الساحه
الفلسطينيه اذا حيث صنفت الامم المتحده
عام 2022 بانه اكثر الاعوام دمويه في حق
الفلسطينيين مشيره الى ان حوادث قتل
وانتهاكات ارتكبتها القوات الاسرائيليه
والمستوطنون اليهود خلال تلك الفتره في
حين اتجه الموقف الدولي مع وصوله حكومه
الياهو للحكم مجددا الى تحذير من مخاطر
التصعيد والدعوه المستمر
تتشابه اعوام الفلسطينيين تحت الاحتلال
لكن عامهم الذي سبق هذا كان له تصنيف خاص
ليس اصحاب الارض والقضيه من صنفوه بل هي
الامم المتحده من قالت عن عام 2022 انه
كان الاكثر دمويه منذ بدات المنظمه في
احصاء شهداء فلسطين بشكل منهجي عام 2005
الى ان العمل الماضي شهيد رقما قياسيا من
اعمال العنف الاسرائيليه خصوصا في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
جرائم الاحتلال التي كانت تنفذ اما برصاص
الجيش او خلال اعتداءات مستوطنين يهود
اوصلت عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين عام 2022
الى نحو 230 شهيدا من بينهم 44 طفلا الى
جانب ما يزيد على تسعه الاف جيريح على مدى
عام من تولي حكومه بنت السلطه في اسرائيل
زادت وتيره جرائم الاحتلال
يذكر المقررون الامويون في بيانهم اسرائيل
بانه في انتظار تفكيك احتلالها غير
القانوني فيجب معامله الفلسطينيين في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله كاشخاص
المحميين وليس كاعداء او ارهابيه الواقعه
امر اخر والا لما شهدنا مثلا اغتيالات في
الشوارع وعلى الحواجز الامنيه
ولما تكثفت عمليات الدهم والاعتقال وتجريف
الاراضي وهدم المنازل او مصادرتها
زاد في تلك الفتره الدفع قدما بمخططات
الاستيطان نحو التنفيذ
واستمرت محاصره قطاع غزه مع ابقائه في
حاله من الضغط الامني والاقتصادي الدائم
كما توالت اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى دون
مراعاه لمشاعر العرب والمسلمين كانت تعين
العالم تراقب والسنته تدين عنف المستوطنين
حين وحينا استخدام القوات الاسرائيليه ما
يوصف بالعنف المفرطي ضد الفلسطينيين
لم تخرج المواقف الاوروبيه عن تلك الدائره
مع التحذير من عواقب استمرار مسلسل
التصعيد
ايضا مع مقدم حكومه اسرائيليه جديده تسير
على هدى من اليمين المتطرف والصهيونيه
الدينيه
حكومه
برنامجها القائمه على توسيع الاستيطان
وتشديد السيطره على القدس مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي
ايضا عن قلق اداره
الحكومه الجديده بشان توسيع المستوطنات في
الضفه الغربيه
من واشنطنطينيه
عضو مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي السابق
والدبلوماسيه السابق في سفارتي الولايات
المتحده في مصر واسرائيل
السيد
من الذي سوف ياتي به
وزير الخارجيه الذي يصل خلال يومين الى
المنطقه
من خلال الغاره الاسرائيليه في جنين حادث
اطلاق النار في القدس على الكديه صوره ثم
في منطقه
المستوطنه داخل القدس اذا تركي تركي
التنسيق الامنيه بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والسلطات الاسرائيليه هذا ما ستركز عليه
الزياره
الاسرائيلي
هل سوف يتم الضغط على حكومه
لتتاخذ اجراءات حقيقيه بدل التصعيد الذي
تنويه
وتهدد به في هذا الوقت
المهم انا ادراك الاداره الامريكيه في هذا
اللحظه لا تمتلك الكثير من الادوات التي
يمكن ان تستخدمها للضغط على اي من رئيس
الوزراء الى درجه كبيره حقيقه بسبب
اغلبيته الظهيره في الكنيسه موقفه صعب
ايضا الرئيس
ايضا لديهم نطاق ضيق جدا وهامش ضيق جدا
للمناوره وهذا ينطبق على كده طرفان لكن
بامك
تبدا بانخراف دبلوماسين مع الطرفين بدرجه
اكثر كثافه تكرارا اما فعلته في الاشهر
الماضي ايضا عليها ان ترسم حدودها الحمراء
ومبادئها
ايه هي بالتركيز لذاكره الطرفان على
التهدئه وعلى عدم التصعيد هذه ايضا ستكون
فعاله يعني ما الذي يعنيه مبادئها الحمراء
واذا كان السيد البلانكا ليس لديه اوراق
يضغط بها فهل اتى هو ويليامز رئيس
الاستخبارات وكذلك سلفا مستشار الامن
القومي هؤلاء جاءوا فقط لتسجيل الموقف ام
لديهم انجازات حقيقيه يمكن هم ان يحققوها
او السؤال هو كيف دون اوراق يضغطوا بها
كما تقول
كيف
الغرض
هو ليس التركيز على
العنف الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي بل على
التهديد الذي تشكله
ايران وايضا على المناورات العسكريه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وارسال رساله
ثانيا تعزيز ما تم تحقيق
ذلك
في الضفه الغربيه
الاستفزازيه وزياره الحرم الشريف تريد من
السلطه الفلسطينيه ان لا تطلق تصريحات
استفزازيه والارض نفس الطبق على الحكومه
الاسرائيلي هناك المزيد من الالات المتحده
ما يمكن الولايات المتحده تفعله من خلال
وضعه هذه المبادئ للالتقاء على التهدئه
الموقف لان الامزجه وايضا الحده التوتر في
تصعد لذاكره الطرفين
شكرا جزيلا لك
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي السابق
والدبلوماسيه السابق في سفارتي الولايات
المتحده في مصر واسرائيل
مجموعه من الاجراءات تتجه حكومه اقصى
اليمين في اسرائيل لاعلامها وذلك بعد
الاجتماع الطارئ ردا على العمليتين اللتين
شهدتهما القدس في ساعات ال 24 الماضيه لكن
ماذا يختلف عن اجراءات تصعيد سابقه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي في ظل حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو الخامسه ساده التوتر في شهر مايو
2021 اذا قرار قضائي اسرائيلي باجلاء
عائلات فلسطينيه من منازلها في حي الشيخ
جراح
يوم السابع من مايوفي عام 2021 كان هناك
اصابه لاكثر من مائتين فلسطيني الاحتلال
صعد اعتداءته في المسجد الاقصى ما اسفر عن
اصابه اكثر ااا من 200 بجراح بعضها خطير
ازداد التوتر وشن جيش الاحتلال عمليه
عسكريه واسعه النطاق في قطاع غزه استمرت
11 يوما واستشهد فيها اكثر من 200 و50
فلسطينيه في القطاع يوم الحادي والعشرين
من مايو 2021 دخل وقفه اطلاق النار بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه واسرائيل حيز التنفيذ
واعاد الاحتلال فتح معبر كرم ابو سالم
التجاري لعده ساعات رغم اعلان الهده اعتقل
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عددا من الشبان
الفلسطينيين بينهم 20 في انحاء متفرقه من
مدينه القدس المحتله لكن كيف كان المشهد
الفلسطيني في ظل الحكومه بنت همم
التي حلت من محل حكومه نتنياهو الخامسه
يوصف عام 2022 بانه هو الاسوا في الضفه
الغربيه منذ نهايه الانتفاضه الثانيه من
عام 2000 الى 2005 ففيه قتلت قوات
الاحتلال ما يقل عن 200 فلسطيني فلسطيني
معظمهم في الضفه وخلال النصف الثاني من
العام المنصرم نفذ جيش الاحتلال اكثر من
2000 عمليه امنيه في الضفه الغربيه خصوصا
في منطقتي جنين ونابلس عمليات التصعيد
كثيره ومنها انه في الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر استشهد خمسه فلسطينيين في عمليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه في نابلس استهدفت مجموعه
عرين الاسود وفي التاسعه والعشرين من
نوفمبر قتلت القوات الاسرائيليه اربعه
فلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه وفي الاول من
اغسطس اعتقلت اسرائيل القياديه في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي باسم السعد في الضفه
الغربيه وفي الخامس من شهر اغسطس ايضا قتل
جيش الاحتلال اثنين من قاده الجهاد
الاسلامي في غزه وما تيسير الجعبري وخالد
منصور اضافه الى عدد من عناصر الحركه
واستشهد في هذا الشهر 49 فلسطينيا في قطاع
غزه من غزه ينضم الينا سعيد بشارات الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه استاذ سعيد اهلا
وسهلا بك ما الذي يمكن ان يختلف الان ااا
ونحن نعلم ان هناك اجراءات مماثله
واجراءات متصاعديه كبيره في حكومه نتنياهو
السابقه وبعد ذلك حكومه بنت ولد
ما يميز الحكومات السابقه لنتنياهو انها
كانت حكومات يمين تقريبا همم يغلب عليها
الطابع العلماني الان همم استلم الحكم كما
ذكر ذكرت همم نفتالي بنت واستوحى العمل
همم وفقه كتاب عثر عليه عندهم اسمه مصيده
67 لشخص مغمور كان اسمه ميخاجمن وبناء
عليه اشتغل وكان همم يعتمد مبدا التقليل
من الاحتكاك منح احتياط او منح اقتصاديه
للفلسطينيين ولكن لم ينجح بشكل كبير وشفنا
ايش صار في تلك الفتره الان هذه الحكومه
مختلفه كليا عن كل حكومات اسرائيل لمده 48
لانها تحتوي على اليمين الكامل مثل ما
بيسموه هذا اليمين الكامل له مشروع اي ده
لوجي يتعلق بالاستيطان ذكره في الاتفاقيات
وهو عباره عن السيطره على الاداره المدنيه
والم واداره حياه المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه وذكروا بقيت قمر بين في اتفاقياته
مع نتنياهو انه يريد الشرطي يريد ان يسيطر
على الشرطي من اجل ان يطبق مخططات وما
يتعلق بما ذكر اليوم مثلا هدم البيوت
الفلسطينيه ترحيل العائله هل هو الخاصيه
الشادر على تنفيذ ما يهدد به
واحيانا يشار الى ان المستشار القضائيه
سوف تعطل هذه الخطوات هل بالفعل يستطيع
تنفيذ ما يهدد به على الارض
اعتقد وفق السلوك السياسي الحالي العمليات
على الارض يستطيع لماذا يتمر بني كبير لا
يوجد عنده حدود دبلوماسيه او علاقات عامه
مثلا تكون له والله سيؤدي اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى الى توفير الاوضاع ما بعرف هذه
الامور بيقول سادخل المسجد الاقصى
امنع اي همم سياده اردنيه على المسجد
الاقصى وانفذ ما اريده اليوم هو قال همم
لقائد لواء الشرطه في القدس اغمض عينيك
ونفذ كل ما حللت به في القدس اذا هو سينفذ
بشكل عملي الايام الماضي يشوفنا اشياء
عمليه على ارض الواقع تنفيذ العمليه في
جنين بهذه الطريقه ومدحها من الجزيره الذي
قال قبل دخول السبت انه قتل 10 وسيستمر في
هذا القتل والموجوهين عضو اللقاء نطمع
لمزيد من الدماء
يطلبه ما الذي يريدون تحقيقه بشكل الواقع
الا انه عندما يقول نفذ كل ما حلمت به هذا
الحلم من الوارد ان يتحول الى كابوس
هذا الكابوس هل سيستطيع نتنياهو لا اعلم
همم سترينا الايام القادمه هذه للتطورات
الى ماذا ستقول هو الان يخطط لتهجير الشيخ
جراح يهدد بتهجير همم سلوان يهدد باعقاب
جماعي للفلسطينيين الحديث اللي بيذكره لا
وسائل الاعلام واللي بصدره على التيك توك
خطير جدا خطير جدا وليس استفزاز فقط هو
يشعل الحرب عندما يقول اغمض عينيك ونفذ كل
ما حلمت به هذا اعلان حرب هذا يفوق عمليه
السور الواقي لا العلم بس يفوق عمليه سور
الواقي اذا هو ينفذ كل ما يريده نتنياهو
تقريبا الموافق على هذه الامور التي يقوم
بها همم
لذلك ويقول بس لا تستعجل نصف خلينا ننسق
مع بعض نجلس في الكافينيت لذلك لاول مره
نتنياهو يعقد جلسه للكافنات مباشره بعد
العمليه ليش لانه عارف انه دمار بني كبير
سيطول سيرتكب ااا امور لا يريدها نتنياهو
شكرا لتتدرك بشكل طبيعي الان عقد الكابنات
شكرا شكرا معذره على المقاطعه شكرا لك من
غزه سعيد بشارات الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا نقل
مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
ان الوضع في بلده اوجليدار بشرق اوكرانيا
صعب لكنه تحت السيطره وقالت المصادر من
القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدى لمحاولات التقدم
القوات الروسيه
وتكبدها خسائر كبيره في يوم الاداره
واقليم دومباز في المقابل وصفت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في دنيات كالمعارك التي
تدور بالقرب من اجل دار بالعنيفه واعلن
حتى ان القوات الروسيه تمركزت في الاجزاء
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه واصبحت تسيطر
على الكره المحيطه بالمدينه
هذا واكدت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
دنيتك تعرض احياء سكنيه لقصف اوكرانيه
بينما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قتلى وجرحى من المدنيين سقطوا في قصف روسي
على مقاطعات خرسا وذافروجيه في جنوب
اوكرانيا وقالت وكاله نيوز ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت ضربات صاروخيه استهدفت مناطق
الصناعيه
في انفجارات عنيفه
قال المستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
تجري مفاوضات مع شركائها بشان توفير
الطائرات والصواريخ البعيده المدى في اسرع
وقت مؤكدا في تصريحات وتلفزه حاجه
اوكرانيا اليها لحمايه المدرعات المقدمه
من قبل الشركاء واوضح بدريا كان بلاده
بحاجه الى تدمير مخازن القوات الروسيه
والقذائف المدفعيه لانها ادواتهم الرئيسيه
حسب قوله
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نصل الى نهايه جوله
حصاد هذه الليله اعطينا فيها تطورات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه تطورات المتسارعه هنا
شكرا على متابعتكم تغطياتنا مستمره بطبيعه
الحال على مدار الساعه لكل ما يقرا على
هذه التطورات